learners permit thursday is on my
youtube subscribe today hey guys just
want to say thank you so much to uh the
crowd at brea you guys were awesome the
night pants nation tour continues
arlington november 11th through the 13th
cleveland december 9th through the 11th
and la jolla december 17th through the
19th all tickets are available at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan stickler on all social
media all right go
to ryancicle.com get your tickets for
the tour guys thank you to
all the places i've been so far it's
been so much fun to be back out on the
road honestly and to see you guys after
a year and a half of sitting in this
room and not being able to see your
beautiful faces so get your tickets
we're still rolling everywhere right now
um
youtube please subscribe to the channel
that's the way you can help it's a free
easy way you know it means nothing you
everything to us and the patreon if you
guys
look man this patreon is
i never expected someone to solve an 18
year old cold case on my patreon i never
expected to talk to someone with two
[ __ ] okay i never expect to talk to a
woman who yanks [ __ ] out of people
for a living and doesn't even have a
degree okay but it's happening it's
happening on a honeydew with y'all y'all
all right five bucks a month subscribe
today and uh you get a full month if you
subscribe for a year excuse me you get a
full month free and you get the honeydew
a day early ad-free all right so if you
or someone you know has that story has
to be heard submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com alright that is the biz and
you all know we do over here we
highlight the low lights and as i always
say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers
that said this is the first time we've
done something like this we actually
have two storytellers today ladies and
gentlemen please welcome josh and jacob
wolf welcome
all right
okay
so
first of all welcome what's going on
so first
it's the first time i've had two guests
on in this situation i did have the
sclar brothers on back at ymh studios
it's the first time i've had multiple
people on the mic with video we had
audio early early on but um thank you
both for being here man thanks for
having us you're welcome and um this was
something you brought up to me and i
thought it was really interesting
because we've never done anything like
this so before we get into what we're
going to talk about please i know you've
got a special you're on the road you
guys have a podcast promoter at all
all right um well my special came out on
october 19th
it's called here for the fun
i will tell you like
it's the most me i've ever put into a
project
the what's happened since i left la for
me has just been
how long you been gone now
i'm like a year and a couple months is
it over a year already jesus you're in a
couple months okay and i i just feel
i just feel
good man i just feel good and
i've kind of cut out a lot of the
outside noise
and so this special is a hundred percent
just me weird fun
since i made it and produced it and shot
it and all that [ __ ] i shot 90 minutes
and i was like you know what it's
youtube i'm just going to keep it 90
minutes we kept you know i made i would
make a mistake and start over and i
don't ed that [ __ ] out because so you
feel like you're at the show it's the
best thing i've ever done without having
friends all right and it's on the
youtube channel and then you tell him
about the podcast matt yeah man we just
started a podcast called hey man hey man
um and it's just us man it's just us
rambling going about it talking about
what's going on or what we used to do
reminiscing talking about the future
everything and anything it's either
super funny or super serious will go any
which way and well you know it's a lot
also
if i get parenting questions i'll get
parenting questions but he gets kid
questions like it's a lot it's a little
bit for everybody and you know he and i
have a
definitely an open relationship
absolutely so you might hear you know
he's admitted you know he admitted dude
dude you know he admitted to me on a
stream
he was like it's like that time i walked
in on you and mom i go what oh yeah
you never do it no no
how old were you he goes 17. i was like
my senior high school what all right
let's start
i'm excited about this because i just
started doing a web series with my step
song called learners permit where he's
getting his driving hours and i'm just
sitting there and telling him stories
about you know we're getting to know
each other better yeah through
learning you know and driving and [ __ ]
but this you've come on in the past
you've told your stories about being a
single dad raising how many kids total
three right yeah and are you the oldest
youngest youngest okay so um
i'd like to hear your point of view on
the upbringing i don't again i'm not
trying to make you specifically remember
stories about how your dad would steal
peanut butter and jellies and ralphs for
your kids but
[ __ ] like i want to hear
like your point of view because i was
this kid you're being raised by a single
dad the way i was and i said outside
it's against mother nature it's not
father nature it's [ __ ] nature
and it's not father nurture like we said
these titties are unproductive you know
i was like you can suck on them but
these are some unproductive titties yeah
and if something comes out i'm sorry
yeah
let me know because i need to get there
exactly do
i had a friend of mine growing up he was
like i got lakers i'm like what is that
maine man
he was like sometimes stuff comes out
i'm like i don't like that that's not
good no you gotta talk to them
[Laughter]
as a kid who grew up with his dad like
that i am very interested to hear
your side of things so let's go back to
the beginning yeah um you're the
youngest youngest so all right real
quick for you how many biological
children do you have
him just him yep all right so
you go
well take us to the beginning you
you're born what year i was born march
17th 1997. and 97. okay and how old are
you when he's born 28.
okay so you're young man 28 you're born
97 and you but you already have two kids
i am with my ex who has two kids okay
now is this x your mom yes it is
biological biologically yes right yes
okay
but the other children are how old her
two that you've already taken in well
they were born in 92 and 93
right so we're talking when he was born
and you're 97 all right so there's a
five-year window between all these
[ __ ] kids yeah okay
so you come into the world and you've
got what a five and a three-year-old
maybe at the time
and where is mom
uh the bi
she's your mom who had you out of her
body yeah yeah yeah i i think there was
a point and correct me if i'm wrong but
i think there was a point to where she
was kind of there early on like when i
was you know super super young but i
think at a certain point he just he took
all three of us and was like hey i
this is the best thing for them you're
not fit for this role and i i'm i'm
taking all three of these kids and going
to raise them the right way and and i
think that's how it happened but i don't
know
how old i was when that happened but i
know i was i was what do you really know
you know you were told that obviously
but what you really remember is what how
old do you remember like remembering and
then being like okay i'm with my dad and
i have these what is a brother and a
sister
so wait you're all you guys are all by
uh biologically right yeah right clear
and a half yes yeah we're all yeah we're
all about half shit's blood yeah yeah
we're all blood so you have a brother
and a sister with your mom
you just have him with her
yes is the father of the your brother
and sister the same guy
yes it is okay so we have two men
involved with three kids
but you
are telling me that you're taking the
three kids so where's this dude
i mean
don't
he's out of the picture that at the time
he was or he's always been out no he he
was out after so yeah he was out
and disguised yeah yeah yeah
are they in their own [ __ ]
picture
it's like all you over here and they're
over
aren't y'all supposed to be in this
picture yeah but we're in this one right
here
no that dude was out of the picture that
dude was out of the picture for a minute
i was out of the picture for a minute
look you know
before i could afford a lawyer
he would send like this dude this other
dude would send either birthday checks
that bounced
or he would send one for like ten
dollars but he would postdate it
do you know what i mean
all right so wait so yeah
you've obviously met this man and
everything if you're taking his children
in i didn't meet him pre-taking the
children this this was a man that was
okay with you taking his children in and
not even [ __ ] meeting you
so we know what type of person this is
at the time everybody can change i don't
know where it's gonna go
but at the time we've got
two pieces of [ __ ] in this
is that [ __ ] on this bookshelf
yeah that's about exactly what it is
that's not exactly what it is
uh so
um all right so now at age what do you
when are you officially a single dad
like when do you have all three of these
kids with you i feel like 99 is the
right day and that's when you're about
two-ish yeah yeah all right so what do
you remember um earliest like moving
forward from there earliest i remember
that i remember that one bedroom or the
apartment in hollywood um i remember bud
for a brief amount of time which was
gigantic and would guard me from my
older brother um yeah he did he did not
like my brother because trevor would go
and [ __ ] with him and like pull his ears
and all that and i would just sit there
with him and i would sit you know he
would curl up and i would sit in his
stomach trevor would walk by and bud
would like stand up and just yeah my
damn he was way more cujo than beethoven
truth like
he was also way more mom than your mom
yeah and way more dead than their dad
[Laughter]
okay so you remember early days um
when when does it hit you at what age do
you realize that what's happening to you
is different in school like you start
talking to friends or your friends like
cause i remember for me just to set you
up i want to say third fourth grade yeah
people would talk about my parents are
divorced i'm like oh my parents you know
and i didn't start not feeling like such
a weirdo and an outcast yeah yeah so
your mom was in and out for a little
while you're saying like in the
elementary school years and would that
be fair yeah i mean from honestly i
think until i was about 13 which is
around seventh or eighth grade we went
up we like alternated christmas and new
year's and summers so we would go up for
about two three weeks uh she lived in
washington at the time so we would go up
on vacation and hang out i wouldn't
really call it hang out but we would go
visit and what would you do when you
visit what do you remember she worked 12
hours a day so every time i came up i
brought my gaming console with me or my
brother had one so that's where i
learned to really how to play video
games and do all that stuff but i sat in
my room and played video games for
probably 12 hours a day and then you
know
the promise of coming back and we'll you
know make dinner and hang out as a
family turned into uh hey there's stuff
in the fridge i'm going out
and she would just go out and drink with
her friends and oh okay so she wasn't
working a 12-hour day coming home be
like i'm exhausted i'm not gonna no no
no no i'm here she out she went out and
did her thing because that's what she
wanted to do um and so
the kids who were me and kate kate my
sister and my brother we suffered a
little bit one i threw that for sure
yeah for sure
i didn't know about that right but all
three of them are living with you
there's not like you're not split at the
time okay uh my sister went back and
forth okay i know like we all were here
for a little bit until i think
t was about so nine they were all here
for a little bit and then she was like
hey i'm
because i didn't have any rights to the
oldest two kids right right and so but
the people who did this
were like we don't want to run
then she called and she was like hey
they're coming to live with me and there
was really nothing that i could do about
that legally right but
they always knew that they could come
back whenever and so my daughter came
back
went back and forth and my oldest son he
came back for eight months once he did
yeah yeah
what age on bellingham oh that's where
that photo's from yep yeah okay got it
got you got it now when they went up
there did they stay with her or did he
go on his own
your bro your son your oldest son oh he
stayed with her they all said yeah yeah
and then we visited obviously we stayed
and we stayed with her and like shared
bedrooms and did all that [ __ ] um
but i would say probably yeah around
like fourth or fifth grade i started to
kind of really think
because you know we still visited so to
me she was still you know my mom and
still who was my mother and all that
[ __ ] um but then
it started to dawn across me a little
while later that she wasn't
you know she wasn't doing her part she
wasn't really there and it
what made you realize that just not
seeing her and all the false promises
and everything that just fell through
she's telling you she's gonna see you
and yeah it's not like she just it
wasn't there yeah and then maybe there
was like one day out of those three
weeks maybe two that we'd spend the
whole day together as like a family but
how would that feel it was you know it
was good and that part it was good
because that's what us as kids wanted we
wanted to just hang out with
our family because we're only there for
three weeks and we don't get to see her
amen at all so we're taking any chance
we can get and so and that's also this
what um
what's one of the false promises that
really [ __ ] still just
got you
uh uh next time or tomorrow night like
there's a specific one you're like man
she said she was gonna take us to the
aquarium i got one about him
this [ __ ] said he would take me
to sea world when i was four and that
was 20 years ago what the [ __ ] man
oh there it is
sea world ain't even here that [ __ ] up
still again man i mean i don't even
remember saying all right you say [ __ ]
like yeah yeah yeah sea world yeah yeah
it means nothing to us that's the same
that's the lesson as a parent yeah at
four
oh yeah we had a little money to go to
seaworld yeah but we
um
okay so
mom's making false promises and stuff
and you're living with dad at the time
yeah yeah i was i only ever lived only
ever lived with
i got full custody him she never showed
up right in court
wait
so when i she just didn't show up she
gets served you know my so my brother i
go hey can you serve
so and so and he was like yeah so he i
remember him calling me and going
what should i wear i'm like this isn't a
tv show dude you're not a cop just put
your jeans on your t-shirt and hand her
the envelope he was like but should i
wear sunglasses i'm like
is it going to be sun
i don't know how to answer that man
but yes so he served her
and she just never showed up
so
then i have to ask you this as a child
who's had this happen to him
what does it feel like to not
to
to be the one not picked
you know it it definitely was did it
[ __ ] with you it definitely a little bit
because it felt like that she wanted
those two more than me or like that we
were different in any some sort of way
um
but here's the other thing it's it's
tearing you apart in several ways
because now your brother and sister are
going so you're losing that camaraderie
and relationship on a daily basis right
you're also being told
in your process that hey
these two you value more or you want
more than me or they're better than me
or you know there's something about me
that you don't want why wouldn't you
take all three of us yeah absolutely was
there ever a time
and i'm just asking and curious because
i know where we are right but was there
ever a time where you like i wish i had
been able to go live up there all at any
age where i wish i could go probably
right after sea world
after that never happened
every every year to see world things oh
yeah it's like sea worlds right they got
real killer whales up there watching
them like you're right you're right go
watch those
um was there ever were you like i i you
know for whatever she felt more fun or
it felt like it was gonna be more fun up
there because your brother and sister
were up there for a bit it only felt
more fun because i was just doing
something different you know i was
getting on a plane and like you know
this the flight attendants would walk us
up to the gate and i was out there alone
you know you'd walk me to the gate and
they'd walk me onto the plane and i'd
get to get on first you know all that
other stuff so it was just like a fun
experience to be able to like travel as
a kid and like you know just do
something different they're finding a
positive in it yeah
but
but there i don't think there was ever a
time i wanted to live with her
that's a lot of change and also let me
ask you did you not want to live with
her because you knew she didn't want you
or was it a [ __ ] you back or did you
really enjoy being with your dad more
because i always enjoyed my father more
like there was just something
not there was something there was
definitely something about my mom like
from the i remember telling her like
i was like when dad tucks me in at night
i don't [ __ ] move
you don't ever tuck me in you know if
you even came over and touched the bed i
kicked the sheet like
that
you know i just knew you weren't a good
person to me and i always was down for
my dad i didn't really really i didn't
realize it until a little later in life
probably like honestly high school was
when i really got the bigger picture of
everything that was happening um but no
i enjoyed my life down here in l.a i i
never questioned it when i
think about it and wherever when i
thought about it i was like no this is
this is my home you know what i'm saying
like this is where i belong and it's
here with him and my my mom who stepped
into the picture um
like this is this is my home and so i
never second guessed it i was sad to
leave because at that time you know i
still
thought there was a big relationship
between me and my biological mother and
so it was always hard to leave because
you know you go six seven months without
seeing her so it's a bummer and i don't
facetime was not a thing at that time
are you communicating like are you
texting calling is there any of that or
is it just you see you when we see you
uh there was like you know
i didn't have a phone you know i didn't
have a phone until
until i stopped
talking to her stop seeing her so that's
when you're like now you can have it
you're like
you're ready you know here you go yeah
yeah iphone 3 right here
exactly
exactly that's right got some
pre-blocked numbers on it don't worry
about that [ __ ]
yeah it was uh i i never i never second
guessed it this is where i belong and i
knew that for a long time and then
looking at everything also after it it
was
and also it wasn't my choice i i know
that i knew there was never
a chance that i was going up there
anyways that was also another thing i
desired there was also a period of time
dude where
you and i just because of your age and
our money situation
we were together
24 hours a day right he would come to
auditions with me
sit next to me when he was two i
remember in a baby bjorn doing an
audition whispering because i didn't
want to whisper wake him up and the
casting directors were like that was
really cute but we can't tell if you're
good or not you know what i mean like it
was so silly this is for bud light yeah
yeah yeah we're gonna need some more
yeah
but but um
so there was even a i think at that
young age i
he i think he knew like this is where
yeah absolutely this is where i am
absolutely yeah if you're carrying a
credit balance month after month it can
feel like you're in a never-ending cycle
of debt with no end in sight upstart can
help you make that final payment so you
can get ahead upstart is the fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date rather than
looking at credit score alone upstart
considers other factors like your income
your current employment and credit
history to find you a smarter rate for
your loan you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score in
minutes for loans between 1 000 all the
way up to 50 000 and you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com honeydew that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application that's
upstart.com
honeydew flu season is in full swing
proper hydration and vitamins can help
support a strong immune system all right
are you going to be enjoying a few extra
drinks now the holidays are approaching
yup this is what you need not only that
but the product tastes great with
flavors like watermelon strawberry and
lemon lime you all know it i talk about
it all the time my favorite one is the
orange i like the citrus it's got that
vitamin c got that vitamin d got all
those things i need when i fly every
time i work out i put it in a water
bottle take it to the workout with me i
put a liquid iv in a water bottle when i
walk and i definitely take liquid iv on
my flights on that night pants nation
tour come see me tickets available ryan
liquid iv hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone made with
clean ingredients non-gmo vegan and free
of gluten dairy and soy alright grab
your favorite liquid iv flavors
nationwide at walmart or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code honey do it check out that's 25 off
of anything you order when you get
better hydration today using promo code
honeydew at liquidive.com
so then you get into what you said about
fourth fifth grade you start learning
about man my mom stops coming around is
that when it's sort of like wish that
when the tie was broken
well she never
made the effort to come around if
anything it was just us you know going
up to see her in washington she never so
once you served her and she doesn't show
up i'm saying like did she not
just go
just
you know ghost from there or you could
still see her when you went up there
you know when she didn't show up she
still lived here oh she was here she
still lived here you didn't know that no
i i i didn't even worse i didn't even
know that she didn't she
when it's not a plane ticket yeah
absolutely she
she
a bus
yeah not even a cat like yeah
um yeah no no that was here that was dan
served her here
uh the coffee bean up on sunday i had to
have been super young though like you
were yeah man that was her answer was a
no-show you were there but i was there
yeah yeah look she had her own issues
man sure she had her own issues i'm just
asking yes and she had her own issues
and
when that happened she was still here
and then i don't think
she moved back up to seattle it might
have been another
eight months or so but she was living in
a different spot and we had moved
um out of the one-bedroom place into a
house and that's when it really started
to just
it just wasn't an everyday communication
it gradually started to get longer and
longer in between absolutely yeah okay
and and
you know the decision at 12 12 13 yeah
to for him not to go back up to seattle
that's when that's when you were 12 13
is well the last time that he was like
yo you you're not going back up there
anymore i told him does that mean no
visiting or anything
there just was not
for my satisfaction yes
there wasn't enough
he was alone too much which yeah which
is fine look if you go to work that's
cool i understand that i i you know i
was a single parent who worked
and like so i totally get it but like he
can't be alone at night too and you
remember new year's eve when you were
alone yeah i did very much
how that was that same time it was me my
sister
one of her friends
but you remember that time she brought
you to the neighbors for new year's eve
oh yeah where i went and had an asthma
attack and almost [ __ ] died and it
was like 2 a.m and thank god she
actually answered the phone because she
was out drinking so i remember that
i mean it was new year
i mean give her a break yes you know
what i'm saying i'm not gonna let you
just [ __ ] on the woman the whole time
i mean he's right new year st patrick's
day halloween you know what i mean
but that is when
uh
beth and i
you know his mom and now that's what i
want to ask you real quick when does she
how old are you when beth comes into
picture four okay very young okay yeah
and so
we
i was just like here's a deal and she
and i talked and i was like he can't go
back up there
it just i at some point like
he comes back and it's almost
i'm almost like i don't recognize this
dude when he comes back i'm like i don't
recognize what's different attitude
energy energy um
a little bit attitude
um and just his
you know this dude super cool and vibey
was high strong came back remember you'd
always come back making weird noises
or some [ __ ] weird like
weird beth and i were always like he
comes back making such weird noises
it was more it was more with my sister
oh was it yeah well whatever it was
yeah it was but but so we were just like
and he was alone a lot
and not happy when he came back
and so i remember we talked to you and i
was like hey what do you think about
this and you were like all right you
were comfortable with that yeah i think
i finally said in that i was that i was
okay not going back up there yeah well
you felt that i'm sure yeah absolutely i
definitely as i got older and then
looking at everything in in hindsight
you go
it's not right it's not there's no
reason for me to be up there but but but
at what point like
was it you weren't
because did you miss going up there i
think like the first time that i didn't
go up there for like a christmas like
what did you miss though your brother
your sister i think i just missed the
fact of because like look when when it
was you know when it was good it was
good that's right yeah and that's that's
the name that's the name of the [ __ ]
game you know what i'm saying that's the
heroine yeah i want that back exactly
it's chasing that so i just and even if
it was just one or two or three days out
of those three weeks it was still
something there's still memories it was
still something i can latch on to until
whenever that next time is but when that
next time didn't come and it was
christmas and it was new years or summer
came around and i was still here in la i
think that first time it was a little
a little shaking but after that it was
it was easy because it was something i
wasn't thinking about
and would you hear from her on your
birthday or was it just a card like what
sort of it was
it was always a text it's always the
text on like thanksgiving and christmas
and new year's and my birthday
the cheesy valentine's day one all of
those but the other two kids live with
her
um at this time yeah at that time my
oldest son
came back when he was
in
fifth grade for almost a school year and
he was just like this isn't for me and
my daughter came back and forth he's
like y'all care yeah
he was like
do you know my daughter told me when she
she so she spent a bunch of years middle
school
up to the beginning of high school and
then went up there for high school and
had to come down here and do her senior
year again and but she told me she was
like yeah i went up there because there
was no rules for high school like there
i know there were a bunch of things that
i wanted to do that i wouldn't be able
to do down here so i went up there
and she and she was like yeah that's
exactly why i went and
it was
not good for her i mean not good at all
and no one with strut without structure
or roles is nothing's good yeah but
nothing good comes from it right but
when but she came back down for her
senior year i think she stayed until her
sophomore year or freshman year she left
over her first freshman year
um and then uh went up there for the
rest of high school and then came back
down and yeah but he was here the whole
time yeah so but the thing that i always
look back on is like
okay well she didn't want you to come
live with her but you could still call
me every day
yeah 100 it's the fact that she never
would come down and visit never flew
down
flew down once with kirk
yeah but that's to be in sacramento for
me to meet her parents that were also
terrible
ah her parents aren't terrible i didn't
have a great time you know what was
insane was the the only thing i can
remember from that trip is me and my
brother and my sister setting 30-minute
timers for each of us to rotate on the
[ __ ] computer that was that old
boot-up aol [ __ ] like
like like it was gray it was dusty it
was like they only used it if they had
to but i remember all of us having
30-minute timers and literally just
alternating on the computer i know that
was all we did there yeah
so you're i hate those poodles too man
oh yeah those buddhas
bro your um
your lack of having a mom in your
day-to-day life how did it affect you
with beth did you did was it resistant
at first or did you gravitate right away
no it was it was right away her energies
she's the best yeah man like you
consider her your mom that's my mom all
the way around does your biological mom
know about oh but i call her by her
first name she knows yeah she knows that
really oh yeah but don't use your first
name tonight no uh no no no how does
that make karen feel yeah
thank you
um i i bet it [ __ ] stings i mean
she's never told you how it makes you
her feel i mean she's she said it's like
you know she said she understands it and
i'm like yeah i would [ __ ] hope you
do like you keep saying you try to you
know get work you know help yourself and
i'm working on it and but there's still
never really been a full-fledged apology
like there's been you know yeah you know
there's been like the small ones you're
like oh yeah i'm sorry i wasn't there
for that or this it's like yeah what
about my [ __ ] high school graduation
what didn't show up for that she didn't
even ask if she could come
like she didn't even make a [ __ ]
effort all through high school the
basketball games the football games the
track meets
homecoming prom any of that [ __ ] like if
she would have asked and tried to make
an effort i wasn't there for prom either
yeah but
yeah were you i was on the road he was
on the road well he's a single dad
well not at the time
and that was okay you know in high
school you know he he did miss a a good
chunk of like football games and all
that but you know i knew the deal he was
out providing for the family and doing
what he had to do and and making people
laugh and that was and that was okay
because he's still just us flipping
dildos
hey man those are great times we love
that [ __ ] but on the three or four days
he was in town we pay our bills yeah
exactly
well the dick jokes
and dicks yeah yeah
apparently
but on the three to four days he was in
town he made the effort every single day
and when he was out of town guess who
was at every single game every single
event every single time it was my mom
and for everything she never missed a
damn thing so you call beth your mom
and your mom whatever her first time
wow that's powerful how does beth feel
about that
she she knows the deal and she knows
like
there's nothing that could happen ever
that would change any of it yeah there's
really no
insecurity
anymore either like she 100 gets it so
your mom's saying she's trying to work
on herself she's told you these things
like what does that mean what is it the
work personal is it yeah it's addiction
yeah it's a little bit everything yeah
it definitely has i don't know if she
still has but she definitely had a
drinking problem for sure um and you
know the drinking would just turn into
like the false promises would come from
the drinking and be fueled by the
alcohol and so it was just a lot of you
know i'm every year we get that i'm
working on myself i'm trying really hard
i'm going to therapy i don't know how
many of those were even true because
everything we heard from her for
probably a decade was just
[ __ ] like the [ __ ] never stopped coming
out of her mouth um so that was you know
it was just at a point to where we just
took everything she said to us pretty
much as that's a bold face lie we just
started reading every text messages yeah
when you guys get all this sometimes
she'd put me and the siblings in a group
chat and send that [ __ ] and i'm like
when then i'd go into our group chat and
i'd be like what the [ __ ] is this
like what the [ __ ] is this kids tables
he was telling me he was like she can't
even send us individual texts anymore
yeah god damn it man it's like it just
goes back to the effort there was no
effort in anything and especially you
know these people would say like uh
my brother hit me i've been meaning to
call you i said what stopped you yeah
did somebody hold you down yeah
like yeah what do you mean you've been
meaning to what the [ __ ] going on
absolutely no do you need help yeah do
you need help calling me yeah i can help
you call me he's a life alert just to
[ __ ] help dial it up i get it like
it's
i say it all the time if people want to
they do they will that's it yeah
you know what you know
he used to you're pregnant you gotta
well
how hard is it to [ __ ] look some [ __ ]
up and be like it's either gonna be
target or some other [ __ ] where they're
registered or whatever how hard is it to
find that and send them a gift or just
send them some [ __ ] you know what i mean
like people who want to will for sure
what's the example do you remember the
example i used to give you for if you
wanted to you would do you remember the
one that and i'll start it and you'll be
like i i think i remember it if i told
you right now so he was
we'd what any example of something i i i
want to try to get him to post let's
look uh he uses this one still today not
using the example but still gets me to
try to do this every day is call my
grandparents because
you know time is about of the essence
and it's all good and i understand that
they're both over 80 and so you know we
gotta you know just check in and say
what's up right one man
which is all around fair and i 100 get
it
the example he would use when i was a
kid was hey
if if i told you right now if you called
your grandma and grandpa for even if it
was five minutes if it was two minutes
if it was 30 minutes that there was a
million dollars for you in it would you
do it i'd be like yeah and he's like
that's it if you just want to do it if
you wanted it you'd do it and i'm like
[ __ ] that man like that's not a million
dollars
i was like do they have a they have one
ready for you
i'll call those [ __ ]
i'll get the whole bluetooth to keep
those [ __ ] on all the time
away
[ __ ] right
do i remember that saying of course i
[ __ ] remember that go if there was a
million he'd go i get it there was a
million but that was the one you hated
so
in school things like that did you feel
that you acted out did or did you act
out um did it come out in different ways
were you bullied were you did you fight
a lot were you angry
what can i can i interject just one
thing where i think it came out but so
you can tell where you but i don't want
to get away where i think it came out oh
well i think i also know but okay okay i
never acted out like i was not a fighter
i was i was uh
you did kick that dude straight in the
chest what dude straight in the chest
yes
so
early on
i didn't need him to learn how to fight
but i thought martial arts was great for
confidence and concentration sure so he
was in taekwondo and he was a black belt
by the time he was nine wow so that was
four this dude straight up could put
could walk into the splits
either way you could do that oh yeah the
most flexible ever like [ __ ] lego
mango yeah eight he could stand in front
of me this close but with his this front
leg straight up like karate kid shot
yeah
he dunked on me once in the driveway and
i was like yeah
i go yeah i go you're never doing that
again he was like no i'll be able to
dunk again i go yeah but you're nuts
that's where you have to yeah i tell
people
yeah yeah you better work on your free
throws you come inside when people say
what's the one thing about childhood you
just would never do again as an adult
and for me i'm always like any kind of
piggy back or chicken because that's
just dicks on your neck it is yeah when
you're a grown-up it's just a dick on
your nose all just gentle on yourself
you're like
yeah
the [ __ ] is that a little tiny ball bag
on my neck squish squirt it out of your
shorts [ __ ]
oh what is that on my neck it's sticky
it's sticking get that peel that off is
that silly putty what
is that
all right so you didn't fight but were
you bullied were you picked on i was
bullied but not for that i was bullied
for other reasons i was bullied because
i grew my hair out this is the longest
my hair has been since i was 13 and i
grew my hair out for about a year to
donate to locks of love
because my grandmother at the time she
was diagnosed with cancer for i think
the third time uh and so i just i was
like you know i'm doing it i'm doing it
and i i stuck out that [ __ ] for a year
and it was you know he took at school
yeah
he took a b a b yeah you know why you
were doing it
nobody ever [ __ ] asked they just they
just wanted to verbally abuse you
i will say i i never got like i can
comfortably say i never got the [ __ ]
beaten out of me when i was a kid when i
got bullied it was all worse [ __ ] that
kid in the chest in elementary school i
mean more high school straight up
high school was where like because that
i when i even was on the football team
the football team [ __ ] hated me for a
reasons i couldn't even tell you i had a
kid pretty much i was getting water and
he just put all pads on and speared me
while i wasn't looking from behind and i
went into each i went into a fence and
my heels almost touched my head and i
got up so angry but this kid's so much
[ __ ] bigger than me and he's just got
and he's not his knees are just like
your knees yeah
he's got one of those uncontrollable
rages that i've seen before and on the
field and aimed at me let them crawl at
you oh yeah man if i could have i would
if i had the confidence i had now i
would have just lined up right on the
line and said let's do it i was just
looking out for the better of my health
because he was head-hunted
he was coming to take my [ __ ] head
off and calling me out for one-on-ones
and i was like dude
no like get the like i'm not putting
shampoo in my hair
[Laughter]
can i tell you from my perspective when
the bullying started
it was it was so fifth grade it was so
weird to me dude and so sudden
we're dealing with a kid who was uh
super popular had a ton of friends these
guys all traveled in a pack just buddies
there was probably like six or seven of
them
and then one day
he was out
i don't know about fifth grade yeah he
was out somebody saw his set yeah i'm
talking all of his parents saw his
but it happened one day
and it was so hard for me to watch
for beth and i there was such a
drastic change in who he was and how he
felt about himself
and i was torn even with the
because i here's two things that i
believe i believe the parents today fix
their kids problems too much
right and so i feel like you're taking
away their ability to problem solve yep
and they're always looking for somebody
else to fix their kids all the time be i
say it that's my line is be a problem
solver figure it out dad this is okay
well what would you do figure out your
problems
right it's important so i'm so [ __ ]
important and so i really always leaned
into the rules of the playground too
look nobody's gonna hold them down and
beat the [ __ ] out of them but yo when
somebody were at the playground and
somebody took his truck and he'd come to
me i'd be like
what are you gonna do
go get your truck whose truck is that
is that your truck like a dog i was like
is that your is that your truck or my
truck it's your truck go get your truck
and he would walk over and grab the
truck and so like
for me that stuff was always really
important but with the bullying stuff
i was caught because i saw the way it
was affecting him i also know as a young
man you know this you know what doesn't
help for your dad to come into school
and say stop picking on my kid yeah that
really doesn't help no so i was like i
can't do that i can't be that guy and
i'm not gonna bring the other kids into
a group in the principal's office and go
oh you're picking on because that's
gonna be worse because now even you'd
rather get picked on than
ignored by everybody which is what's
gonna happen to you right
and so
beth and i i was just like we gotta let
this has to unless he's getting
physically
all we can do is talk to him because the
other option which is us going in is
worse and worse for his psyche sure yeah
mommy and daddy always run to my help
and benefiting aid and i remember
sitting in
i really
i remember sitting in sarah colona's
office at chelsea lately
i had dropped you off at school
and it was the first time you didn't
want to go in and you were like i just
and i was like what's going on
and you're like i just and you just told
me you were like they're just on did he
slow mo do it with the hair like yeah
with he held up a fan
[ __ ]
but
he just told me what's going on and he
was like i'm just a dread walking
through those doors every day and i was
like ugh
and i remember pre-show just sitting in
saracallona's office crying like a just
a baby because i just didn't know what
to do for him and it was changing
my favorite part about him
which is just that personality
do you know what i mean yeah one of the
things that everybody says like he's
just he's happy man
that's a happy kid and he shakes your
hand and he's in conversations and he's
present and all that stuff and that was
just
going away
and i just i felt like 100 lost and we
talked about it a bunch yeah but there's
just not much we could do well the thing
the thing that i wanted to do was not no
and even as i got older the bullying
only got worse and so that idea as i got
older of my dad coming in and talking to
the kids was way off the [ __ ] table
now how'd you go and talk to the parents
remember we remember we were gonna talk
to the parents but then you were like
the parents gonna talk to the kid and
the kid's gonna tell everybody else to
school
yep okay and i was just like that is
gonna happen like the other kids are
gonna find out that we
told
we had to go and have a meeting and you
were like that's not worth it for me
yeah
um
it just uh yeah it only got worse too
just for different reasons i don't know
what happened around that age of fifth
grade but everybody just started
excluding me from things i started
getting stopped getting invited to like
parties and and like birthdays and like
summer [ __ ] like after we'd all played
baseball and everything together too we
grew up at the same park for our whole
entire childhood
we know each other's families we know
each other's parents we know each
other's siblings like were they
different to you too
no
so they'd see you out and still talk to
you and everything yeah it was all and
the parents just pretended like yeah we
don't know just don't talk about it yeah
we didn't i didn't ask him like hey
what's going on because honestly right
that's none of my yeah it's not like
they get to choose what they get to
choose you know what i mean but i you
know
it definitely left a
there has had been one of that group
oh there's a couple in that group that's
delivered
that reached out to me about tickets to
a show
no way is that right dude
yeah well i'll well i'm gonna get that
name later but that's that's really
interesting that's really really [ __ ]
interesting um but yeah i mean as it got
worse
it the
just the effect it had on me started to
get worse too because the insults
started getting worse because we started
getting older started learning new
things there wasn't much insults in the
fifth grade area it was just more like
kind of leaving me out but sixth seventh
eighth grade before i cut my hair
was
was rough sauce
the only
the only good story out of that is my
yearbook picture in my eighth grade
[Laughter]
what is it it
i mean it's a picture man i'll tell you
that oh my god i remember i had a bunch
of friends in like yearbook club and all
that [ __ ] right
and so
i'm right there to like for one of the
first ones online to get the yearbook
because it was important to get your
yearbook first so everybody could sign
it all that [ __ ]
and dude comes out of where he had the
yearbooks and he hands it to me and he
goes
just want to let you know and i go
what that sounds terrible why are you
starting with that and he goes
you look like a witch in your photo i
was like
i was like what what kind of [ __ ]
what is how do you start a conversation
like that i opened the [ __ ] i opened the
[ __ ] book and i was like oh son of a
[ __ ] man i'm a witch brother i son of a
witch he comes home and he drops the
yearbook i go huh what do you think he
goes i look like a [ __ ] witch and i
was like come on and i opened it up i'm
like
that was also when i started to learn to
laugh at myself and i was like yeah okay
that's that's kind of [ __ ] funny
that's that's kind of funny yeah that's
that's that's a big shift yeah yeah yeah
uh and that was yeah but also you take
the sting and the power away from anyone
that's throwing [ __ ] like you should
hear what they [ __ ] say about me at
home this ain't you that's all you got
millions of views the stories on my
youtube page about him have mm-hmm i
mean and that's not just to tell you
that i get millions of views on my
videos what's what's your job
um but but um
everybody knows this [ __ ] and so
they feel like they know them sure so if
you seem public they're not like hey
what's going on they're just shouting
embarrassing [ __ ] adam i can't imagine
i can't i had somebody come to my work
and just start blasting [ __ ] on two
separate occasions i had one guy what
was your what work uh jersey mike's i
was behind the counter making [ __ ]
sandwiches
came in and did one two two separate
people one woman came in i made a
sandwich and there was nobody else in
the lobby it was just her
and as i was cashing her out she was
like hey all right are you jacob wolf
like are you joshua's kid and i was like
yeah like how are you we started had a
conversation she was like would it be
okay with your manager if like we took a
quick photo and was one of my good
friends at the time like one of my best
friends i'm gonna be a groomsman at his
wedding in april and he's like yeah dude
like it'll be quick can i go yeah so i
went on when the lobby took a photo with
her and went on she had a great day she
became one of the regulars and you know
she came in you know every couple weeks
and we talked still and that was fine
and it was great that's an interaction
that i love sure the other [ __ ]
not so much
when you come in and there is a lunch
rush and you get to the front and i'm
slicing eight sandwiches at once trying
to remember who wanted a turkey in an
italian or a [ __ ] philly and you say
hey are you the kid whose dad talks
about him sending dick pics and i'm like
he said that in front of everybody yeah
we had a it was 12 30. not me bro yo it
was 12 30 on a [ __ ] tuesday outside
yeah
come on and i look up and i go and i go
yes sir now what the [ __ ] would you like
to order for your god damn son
and
you've got to get it a lot yeah and i
was like yo i was like and i started
pushing his order faster and i looked at
my line i go get him the [ __ ] out of
here right now because please what
happens to him is that they just repeat
it and then dick pics hey you send that
dick back
and then everybody else is like what the
[ __ ] is he talking about now i'm like
guys i would love to have a story time
yeah
so i was like the sooner i get him out
of here the sooner i can quietly
de-escalate this [ __ ] situation and
act like it never happened we deserve to
know what we're putting in our bodies
and why especially when it comes to
something we take every day rituals
clean vegan friendly multivitamin is
formulated with high quality nutrients
and bioavailable forms your body can
actually use and what you won't find are
sugars gmos major allergens synthetic
fillers and artificial colorants plus
the fresh taste and delayed release
capsule design makes taking your
vitamins easy i take it daily i uh i'm
on the mailing list that thing comes in
the mail boom it's right there i get my
monthly supply sometimes i have more
than enough and i can pause it start it
stop it all that ritual is the
multivitamin reimagined a multivitamin
should contain key nutrients and forms
your body can actually use to help fill
gaps in the diet no shady extras rituals
delayed release capsule design delivers
high quality nutrients including vitamin
d3 and just two daily pills and it's now
available for women men and teens ritual
multivitamins are scientifically
developed to help support different life
stages get key nutrients without the bs
rituals offering my listeners 10 off
during your first three months visit
ritual.com honeydew to start your ritual
today don't get stuck doing the same
workouts that's one of the things that
would always kill me i'm like chest
tries back
so bored okay making progress towards
the future you means overcoming new
challenges and no workout is one size
fits all fitbog creates a fitness
program that continually adapts to you
so you stay challenged with the new
exercises the pacing the intensity based
on where you are and where you want to
be i'm using the app right now i'm
hitting the gym at least four days a
week that's no lie and i go through the
app and i look at the exercises
someone's not gonna lie some of this
stuff's like you gotta do eight pull-ups
i'm like i'm probably not gonna do any
pull-ups right now so i'm gonna but i
can replace that exercise with something
else you can alter the weights in it
everything and it starts adapting and
understanding you and your workouts and
fitbot understands that the path to
achieving your best looks different for
everyone whether you're exercising three
days a week or twice a day every workout
is scientifically proven to be better
than the last and if you don't have
equipment no worries fitbot has body
weight routines for those looking to get
fit at home or on the go pick up the
pace on your fitness journey with fitbit
today and future self will thank you get
25 percent off your membership at
fitbot.me
honeydew that's 25 off at fitbo dot me
slash honeydew now let's get back to the
duke and even when he comes to my shows
man i try to always be like because when
he comes on stage
i always try to like when people ask
about the dick pics or what other
there's a video about him ordering porn
and blaming it on my parents which they
did
anyways um
[Laughter]
you know he gets that a lot too who
ordered the porn which is fun by the way
guys
i
am not complaining i i find it one
because the story's not about me but
for it's incredibly flattering do you
know that p that people connected so
much to it from my point of view it's
amazing from i don't have to be the
person in the story right yeah do you
know what i mean yeah you know and for
some some kids like i get you know he's
got a demographic now of kids who are
between 13 and 18 and so that's you know
i can relate to those kids because i'm
still not in that generation but
somewhat relatable so when they hear
those stories i get kids who dm me and
they're like either like oh my god
you're so stupid like i can't believe
you would do that keep doing dumb things
so your dad has more comedy or hey
you're you're an awesome person [ __ ]
happens like love your dynamic and all
that keep up all that good [ __ ] you make
my day better and it's like see there's
there's two different sides to it
there's there's that one that just
starts to get i'll tell you what's
frustrating really hard for me to live
with
as a
father and a human
is that
no matter how much he tells me it's okay
and the story's okay and
whatever good residual effects i have
there's no escaping i know social media
there's no escaping
how i know it has to make him feel
sometimes
and
i you know
i've tried to be like that but you know
list the positives and be like that but
this outweighs there's no outweighing it
for me like i know and i can hear it in
his voice sometimes it affects him and
that is a really
difficult because even even the jokes
man like
i never post him or would start telling
him until i asked him you okay with me
telling this yeah right are you okay
with me telling this
but
it's like saying are you ready for
prison
yeah i mean for sure you don't know
right yeah yeah yeah you don't know
you're not [ __ ] right no [ __ ] idea
what's gonna happen that's right could
have never can't even make up an example
of what could possibly happen it's going
to be crazier than the [ __ ] that
actually happened yeah but but but like
i'm not ready i wasn't ready for 11
million people nobody knows right
and what it's weird i'm getting people
stopping me now and asking for pictures
and stuff and stella was walking with me
on the promenade and some guy's like you
ryan sickler i'm like does he owe you
money you know
yeah then i'm him and she's like dad is
that normal and i'm like it's not i go i
don't care how many times you see it i
don't care how many times it [ __ ]
happens it's not it'll never be normal
it's not normal for a stranger to stop
you and say i recognize you from this
thing in my hand can i take your picture
what's the same thing i watch you in my
hand yeah it's it's crazy but it's also
crazy it's incredibly
flattering right absolutely incredible
but it's not i'm just teaching her
that's not no
usual no but again but the
the flattering part happens for me
like all the negative aspect of all of
these
flows down to him you get filtered out
you get that because i'm not the dude
doing the [ __ ] in this in this right
exactly i'm the teller of the story no
joke's not about you right right and so
it's like i put your nuts on your dad's
neck right
let me get a big kahuna
[Music]
yeah
oh my god
so
you know it's hard for me man
that's a real slope that's a song no
he's not no no by the way
you said that i was like oh he pulled
that out the [ __ ] house that's in a
big community
it's a philly cheesesteak but it's got
one extra slice of cheese and it's got
mushrooms and jalapenos and onions and
peppers yeah it's got that spice i still
know how that know that whole [ __ ]
menu by heart oh my god i could name
every single man you liked working there
for a while man till that [ __ ] out yeah
[Laughter]
i enjoy the job he's also like i got to
work with some of my best friends and
people who are now some of my best
friends to this day whose weddings i've
gone to like i said i'll be a groomsman
in one of my uh best friend's wedding i
had one of my best friends who worked
there from high school he also ended up
road tripping with us and helping you
move cross-country oh yeah that's right
man you know so he was actually how i
got that job there yeah he's a good dude
yeah so you know it ended up being a
great spot and i could pursue my pa
career there so you know
not pa career you're not going to have a
phd my film career there you go my
and my uh you know what your career yes
cool yeah your career my career
because what's film and tv now in 10
years
and [ __ ] in coffee cups who the [ __ ]
knows that would be actually not just
drinking and watching and watching on
the liquid or if it's in your eyes
that's i mean if you put the glasses on
it is it's all coming all right so your
career yeah and uh and that was the best
part i was there for three years and i
was able to take if i needed to take two
months off
i could get two months off to go do a
show or whatever i needed to do and then
i would come back and still get my 35
hours a week because i worked hard they
knew my spot right they knew how good i
was yes i could open i could close yeah
lunch rush dinner rush whatever it was
i was there and and i also was one of
the only ones who could work or offered
to work saturday and sunday mornings for
three years saturdays and sunday
mornings from 10 a.m to [ __ ] five i
was sitting in that jersey mike's unless
i called it off but i was in there every
saturday every sunday we had the red
zone on the tv so we were able to throw
we were able to do that which was
awesome but yeah man well that's good
by the way
right there yeah and by the way
yeah these other two couldn't even get
in the pitch
they couldn't even be bothered to get
the same picture did you work growing up
work yeah from seventh grade on yeah
same here so and for me jobs at my
friend's junkyard all through seventh
eighth ninth grade we started driving we
started delivering i'm working at old
age homes i'm working newspaper routes
oh yeah i did it
working so
cutting grass shoveling more opportunity
for us to work
before the age of 15 than it was for
them yes for sure yeah but as soon as he
can get a job
i was like you want money
you know what you should do
get a job yeah because
you know for me that was a huge
it was important for him to know like if
i want something i have to work and get
it but he never
he never blinked about it he was like
yeah that's a good idea i was in it i
was in for it and when uh i remember
dropping out of community college and
coming back dude just tell them that
story about so i come back from i went
to lsu for a semester and then came back
uh took clsu the lsu louisiana state
university and uh the one jew
is that right yeah
i was like hey
don't mention you don't need to tell
people you're jewish
this is also the year before the year
before uh the orange man
yeah exactly exactly by the way
you're going to be an undercover jew
here you know what you're saying yeah
when someone says dirty or you need to
worry about how you dress yeah
when someone says dirty jew just agree
with them be like that's right they are
yeah let me get out of here throw
something back on them grabbers
oh my god um and so
came back from lsu took a semester off
worked for a semester
uh and then i told myself i'm gonna
regret it for the rest of my life if i
don't go to school
went to community college uh one right
in the valley right near where we lived
and uh i was there for what
a month and a half
maybe not it was a midterm midterm and
showed up
and um i was sitting in a math midterm
i'm looking to put my name down i feel
like half the first problem and i
thought to myself and i sat back in my
chair i said what the [ __ ] am i doing
here why am i sitting in this math class
again like i i hate this like what i i
can't do it anymore packed up my stuff
walked up to the teacher and i handed it
to my test it's been 25 minutes since
the test started and he looks at me and
goes he does a double take triple take
he's like flipping through the pages
like is this a is this a [ __ ] joke
like you did half the first problem and
i looked at him i said oh i'm not coming
back and he said what and like the whole
class stopped everybody looked up
because i was [ __ ] dead silent and i
go oh i'm not coming back like nothing
gets you or anybody here school's just
not for me i'm going to do
what i want to do and i looked at my
class i turned around
peace and i walked out and i and i never
looked back and i called him as i walked
out i'm in the hallway and he goes he
picks up the phone and he goes hey man
i'm like what's up he goes wait
aren't you supposed to be taking a math
test right now and i go yeah man [ __ ]
that i'm out i'm out like i'm not doing
this anymore if i got to sit through one
more lecture one more essay one more
[ __ ] math midterm i'm going to lose
my [ __ ]
and uh i said i'm gonna get
i was already working at a place called
the counter which is a burger place love
that spot
and uh i was like i'm gonna get a second
job and um and i'm gonna do my
start doing pa work on the side
and that was
six years ago can i tell you i was
a couple things struck me when i got
that phone call one
yo i wish at that age i would have had
the balls to do something like that for
myself
do you know what i mean like it took me
to be a lot older
to be like i don't know if he's so
scared yeah
i don't want to do this so i'm not gonna
like it takes people a long time to
figure that out right you say yes to a
lot of dumb [ __ ] right
he was like yeah that's it and so it
struck me i was like well this dude i'm
i was so proud of the fact that he had
that yeah and then for him to be like to
go and get that second job which was
jersey mike's yeah
i had no questions after that he he
clearly knew what he didn't want to do
so cool
now let's get started on what you do
want to do and and he really the work
ethic has been really do you know when
when when i told him he had to move out
so he comes back you told him he had to
yeah why
because
here's the deal
if you're in college
and you come home
yeah man you got a place if you're a
grown up in the workforce well those
people don't live in my house
and he wanted to be a grown up in the
workforce well then you gotta go do that
you know how did you feel about that
were you ready uh i i think it was
definitely time for me to get out i was
the one semester of college for me was
nice to have my own space and it was
definitely time for me to go ah i
definitely don't want to live in the
house anymore yeah um but at the same
time i was like yeah really man like
that that was kind of quick here's the
thing
i knew that it was going especially for
him
it was gonna be good for him but you but
you there's no way you're going to
convince somebody who's living at their
parents house that out there is better
it's just not no not necessarily not in
this right especially right now [ __ ]
up so this was a couple years back but i
was like get out there
and um
do you remember the video you sent me
yeah the very first day i was living on
my own i had to grow i went grocery
shopper they went grocery shopping with
me and just grabbed some stuff and uh i
remember taking a video and pouring uh
pouring my milk into my cereal and then
pouring a beer into my bong taking a
bong rip and drinking the [ __ ] beer
out of the bong after and eating sugar
cereal and i said you know what man it's
what it's like live in my house i get
sugar cereal if i [ __ ] want yeah
that's the first video he wouldn't let
me eat any sugar cereal in the house
growing up so no soda no sugar cereal no
there was never anything that was like
maybe like it was like ice cream
sandwiches candy drawer you've ever seen
oh the candy drawer it's halloween candy
from
god knows how 80s yeah but it's like
every year we would that's not true your
mom used to redo the candy girl the time
to me it just felt like the same
halloween candy just like i like
leftover halloween candy from that year
and when it ran out luckily it was a
couple months before halloween so we're
like all right we just get to fill that
back up again no we didn't
i didn't grow up like that with sugar
cereal and all that stuff and
i didn't have any soda in the house or
anything like that no no that was a that
was the way it was we didn't have a
microwave for [ __ ] eight years that
was your mom
right but that's
my point my point this is the you know
we didn't have we had and then when we
got it we had to put it in the garage
yeah she didn't want in the kitchen why
she worried it old
she's she just like we're cooking she
just doesn't she's like look none of
that extra if whatever that's cooking is
cooking me too yeah so put it outside
yeah that was you know what i mean yeah
i know whatever yeah whatever who cares
i i would go out to my garage
some pizza or something there was a beer
fridge out there
somebody smoke smoking eating my [ __ ]
man i went eight years without a
microwave they don't come inside anymore
yeah yeah tv's in here yeah the
microwave is out here
i got a little futon out here actually
the minute she told me in the microwave
again can you knock before you come out
here yeah
hey by the way what age did you do you
were you cognizant of me
i wanted to use that word in this good
job thanks
of me smoking weed
i think that time we were walking rock
and i told you that oh yeah i was we
were walking the dog how old are you oh
16 probably probably 16.
walking the dog and we're out it's
probably like 9 30 or 10.
and we're out walking and i decide you
know this is a great time for me to tell
my dad
that i started smoking weed a little
while ago because i started i tell them
everything and it's just you know like
you know we we have a good relationship
and i think that this is appropriate and
you know i
don't want to do it in front of both of
them i want to do it in front of one of
them and see how they react instead of
getting all of the fire at once in case
it was bad so we're out walking and i'm
like hey man it's uh a lot this might be
a good time to tell you that i uh
that i i started smoking weed a little
while ago and he goes okay and i go okay
and he goes yeah can can we just not do
this though while i'm super [ __ ] high
can we talk about this tomorrow can we
talk about this tomorrow i'm pretty high
yeah you were more lenient on marijuana
than sugar
yep yeah
interesting i was here's what i was well
by the way i still am like i smoke weed
and i would tell you right now sugar is
worse for you than weed yeah i agree
absolutely absolutely that's yeah i
think that's proven and but also for me
and i told him this i would prefer you
didn't drink or smoke
i would prefer that
but i also told him i go i live in a i
live in reality i don't live in ideal
world where you're just going to be
perfect until so
my thing was like there's zero excuse
for you two ever being in a car with
someone who's drunk yeah with uber and
he had i was like this is
the money for uber whenever you need it
zero excuse me if i find that [ __ ] out
and i would just tell him also
he would ask me questions there was
never any booze in the house because mom
drank biological so i was like
we're not gonna do that here and beth's
not a drinker and i'm not a drinker
but as he got older
he saw that i
smoked i mean it's hard to miss that i
smoked yeah and so yeah by the way
waving when i didn't and when i told you
i was going for a walk and i was like yo
i'm going to 7-eleven and we had i think
we had like like a small telekinetic
thing early on because when i was like
yo i'm going for a walk he'd be like
he'd be in the dark in his room and my
mom and him watching tv and all i hear
is get me some cookies just from the
[ __ ] bed and i was like yeah you got
it like in my head and i walk out like a
[ __ ] high ass like
are you
serious
just screaming for me and then he texts
me
he would text me and also go and a
couple bags of swedish fish and then i
get seven texts on the five-minute walk
to 7-eleven
he remember
things that he wanted it was [ __ ]
ridiculous do you remember when i was
super high in my room i just texted you
make me a sandwich and you were like
what i could hear him screaming what
what are you saying i'm like make me a
sandwich
i remember one time you poked your head
out and you were like
be who i am in public
and then deny it
in private you know i mean there was
just no way that that could happen
so
yeah i've watched i've seen my share of
the clean comedians who then
i'm like you [ __ ] smoke weed and
drink and fist fighting yeah but you're
up there with all your g-rated [ __ ] huh
yeah interesting i just i live
yes i am who i am i am who i am and
and so i never and i never put a good or
bad on
who you are this is just who i am yeah i
agree and i don't judge yeah and how and
by like for me it was like instead of
like
hiding the weed
basically you saw me
never even
i don't touch we before 8 pm he when he
asked me about it i was like yeah i do
my work it's like a glass of wine for me
and if i don't do my work i don't smoke
the weed
that's how that's what it is for me it's
a reward yep and it's it's like the
glass of wine and so
i you know and that's why i told them
the only green that comes first is money
yeah if anything gets in your way of
making that
it's a [ __ ] problem
yeah absolutely and so yeah man but i
will say also like his willingness to
talk to me about like
i told you with the the take an acid
story when he told me
i don't i don't remember i said to him i
go hey man i'm and i was looking for
some new stage stories i go what else
you got what can you tell me that i
don't i don't know and he was like did i
ever tell that story
but when you and mom were out of town
and i took acid with a bunch of friends
i'm like
no
and he goes okay you still have to talk
in the voice while i'm right here
i imitate him oh
no yeah the only invitation i have of
him is me screaming into the mic because
that's what he sounds like when he
laughs
exactly thank you very much
appreciate that um
but uh yeah no we uh i remember one
night
me and a bunch of friends got some
some really interesting stuff from uh
from our guy i remember this was the
night that we went to his house
and this is the first time i've ever
seen like the acid that no liquid form i
never i only ever got the tabs or all
that i've never seen it in that the
liquid form that you can put on whatever
you want so we walked in and he had
altoids for us six of them and he double
dosed a couple of them gave them to him
and just also side note this other guy
came in and
bought two sour patch kids with the same
thing and then he was like hey can i get
a roadie and i was like how do you get a
roadie of acid this dude stuck out his
tongue and this dude dropped four drops
on his tongue and i was like my man are
you gonna get home and he goes i'm 20
minutes away we'll find out and i was
like oh my god
he already looked ripped out of his mind
when he walked in the door anyways and i
was like well
good luck to you man holy [ __ ] i'm not
going to do that but um a roadie four
drops oh it's like in a row
yeah yeah that's another
different plants
that's [ __ ] ridiculous never in my
right mind when i do that but then
we head back and there's probably
three of us
and we you know the night goes on i i
had like a couple naps here and there
but pretty much i was up for about 52
hours straight i had a concert on that
saturday too that i went to on the tail
end of it that was i got to tell you it
was ridiculous but i remember
kind of going to sleep for a little bit
on friday night
waking up that next morning
for some reason there was a pizza guy
from domino's sitting in the living room
and i was like still there just sitting
there he was sleeping he just like woken
up and i was like hey
[Music]
the pizza guy yeah spent the night and
so i and i'm talking to him and i go man
i'm like what what the [ __ ] are you
doing here all those other pizzas
and he goes and he goes well we party
last night right and i go you weren't on
ass and he goes no just you three and i
go okay good because i i don't want to
be responsible for that [ __ ] and he goes
and i go but also
thanks for not [ __ ] the house you
gotta go he's like what i go you're a
[ __ ] stranger
for real in my parents house get the
[ __ ] out yeah and he's like well i
thought you guys were cooler than that
this and that this and that and i was
like what else did he want to do
pizza man yeah [ __ ] right and i was
like and i was like man
i don't know what you want you're cooler
than that he just spent all night with
you yeah
he's like i thought he was both
sagittarius man what the [ __ ] going on
remember that long talk we had last
night no dude
and then i looked at him and by the way
you might want to go ask for your
[ __ ] job back yeah i mean or go find
another one like good luck to you man it
was fun you remember when you were okay
he was 13 or 14.
and beth and i
see when you ground your kids you're
usually grounded
beth and i had these plans
and but he had done some [ __ ] and i had
to ground him but beth was like we're
not canceling his plans and i was like
oh i think we were out of town
oh was this was yesterday yeah this is
16 by the way i was i was i was i was in
high school okay
so i we're out of town beth and i and i
got a text from a friend of mine tommy
tommy pope was a comic in new york
and he goes uh hey i go yeah and he goes
when instagram had like a front page he
was going instagram front page i go wow
he goes you might recognize somebody
so he was grounded and the deal was look
man we're going out of town
but like i'm checking in
your hair my brother's going to swing by
if you're not here when they swing by
you know you're grounded because i've
he's he had been grounded for an entire
summer before he came home from school
put his book back down and walked into
his room and didn't come out until
[ __ ] september so he knows that like
when we say don't or you get in trouble
this is like being at moms
yeah i'll be karen's yeah
so
he goes like here he is
lil john little john's kid little kid
went to my high school and had a 16
little john little little john little
john junior little john junior little
john jr do you know his actual name was
though uh his name is slade so slate
front page instagram this kid at lil
john junior's birthday party
holding up his phone hey hey dancing
around ohm nightclub in hollywood this
dude he drove my car there you would
never get caught in the 80s
he got in my i go how'd you get there he
goes i drove your car i'm like you took
my car he was like yeah yeah how else
was i supposed to get there like you
weren't supposed to get there you were
grounded he was like yeah i was i was
willing to take the risk on this one
it's and he did worth it very worth it
hold on
i was there for a good a good portion of
time
honestly if i if tommy hadn't called
you'd have got away with it yeah and
guess what
i still got away with it you know why
because i still went to the party he did
he went away with it you
i had posted it which means i already
won because i was already at the [ __ ]
party i mean it didn't matter what
happened after i succeeded with the
music right about that i don't like the
way this conversation
he's right about that though he did he
did get away it didn't matter the
mission was successful whatever came
after in repercussions i was willing to
deal with ryan do you know what he said
to me the other day
he was like hey he was like hey he was
that we're talking about money i go and
i gave him a whole money talk he goes
you're giving me a money time and i go
yeah and he goes all your jokes about me
i'm the indirect breadwinner of this
family
you should be getting that caught fat
indirectly i was like all right dude
yeah directly out of my ball bag
[ __ ]
um all right i want to wrap this up but
i want to
i want to ask a couple of questions so
first of all i got a little extra love
for single parents not just single dads
but moms too anybody that's out there
doing it and really putting it all in
you know i got absolutely a special love
for you for that so
uh thank you you're welcome and you've
done obviously a great job you guys seem
super close
um i obviously also it wasn't always
easy
do you
do you want kids do you know yet i do
want kids because you know for me it's
one of the biggest people i look up to
not height wise but it's okay
yeah most of the time is is him uh and
so for me you know a lot of people don't
want kids because they're scared because
they don't want to do what their parents
said to them right but it's funny
because i want to have kids for that
reason because i want to be the dad
that he was for me i want to be i want
to be i want to be the type of person
that my kids look up to and so i i
definitely want to have kids i'm not in
no rush let me reiterate that no rush
fair enough but definitely excited to be
a father do you that's really awesome
that's very nice
do you uh what do you think you're the
type of guy that could take in someone
else's kids
absolutely yeah absolutely and love them
the same 100
good man
none of this gives you reservations
about being paid you're not you're
you'd rather be and embrace the way your
father was even with all the hardships
and everything then be the way your mom
is absolutely i'm sorry your biological
mom is yeah absolutely i would uh
i want to take what i learned from both
sides though i want to take what i
learned from her which is what not to
[ __ ] do and i want to take what i
learned from him and my mom and and and
know what to do and go and use that and
apply that to however i raise my kids
awesome all right so i ask every
first-time guest and i'm gonna just ask
you this uh i didn't tell you this at
the top and it's i'm pretty interested
because you're would you say 24 yeah so
i always ask advice everyone would give
to their 16 year old self that's only
eight years ago for you so i'm curious
if you think back on what was going on
in your life specifically around that
time
um what advice
eight years later
would you give to your 16 year old self
because i'm gonna bet my ass eight years
from now
it's not the same thing you would have
told yourself back then
i would probably say uh
stop taking everything so serious
because at 16 i still was very you know
i cared a lot about what people think uh
and what people thought and it was
it was very detrimental to me like i
would
when i asked girls certain questions
about what they you know what their type
is or this and that honestly half the
time i would get i would get girls that
would answer just to see if i would do
whatever the [ __ ] they said they didn't
care they didn't they told me [ __ ] that
was false you tell my girls you were
dating no no girls i was just trying to
get to know a girl's like you know what
like what type of guy you're looking for
you know like that basic what do you
look for in a guy just
kind of like and they would tell you to
try to get you to cut your hair or do
something yeah and just like trying me
to change
to fit a certain persona like that
that vine kid or like you know all those
things back in the day this doesn't even
exist anymore exactly and all you know
they show those kids with abs and do all
this and be this yeah
be athletic and like all these higher
standards and then for me i would just
tell myself yo don't
don't
care so much about what other people
think you guys got to start being
yourself you do and you got to be the
best version of yourself because no
matter what
if you had an ass on your [ __ ]
shoulder it's that's somebody's [ __ ] out
there
somebody out there is like that's my
[ __ ]
absolutely it doesn't matter what you
got it is somebody's [ __ ] absolutely
yeah absolutely well thank you both
thank you uh for coming on promote again
everything you'd like to plug and
promote please do your socials uh uh
instagram jake underscore wolf that's
where i'm most active uh i guess tick
tock if that's the thing here uh uh it's
jake wolfe uh and then i'm gonna meet
him by here
i mean he's calling you calling both of
us yeah not just me though i thought
that was here well i mean listen i heard
it i hear it all the time
yeah you right yeah
when i picked one at the airport i gave
him a hug and i was like what's up old
man he's like all right man like come on
um and then obviously our podcast hey
man it's gonna be out uh and you know go
check that out and go see what's up and
uh you know a lot more to come hopefully
all right yeah i will tell you
man you know my favorite he loves giving
me [ __ ] he was calling me pops for a
while i still call you pops it's your
name and my phone in all caps it is in
all caps is pops and nothing else
comedianjoshwolf.com for tour dates i'm
out guys i'm out every weekend
because my special came out on october
19th on my youtube channel so i'm out
trying new stuff and um my live shows
are now like
interactive weird just happenings if i'm
in your city i promise you
if you see two shows it'll be two
completely different shows
yeah it's two completely different shows
and so i cannot promise you that same
thing
if you was lucky for you to stay for the
second would you go see the same [ __ ] so
josh wolf here for the fun is on my
youtube channel check it out and then um
check out our podcast hey man and by the
way when he turned i i saved pops when
he turned 50. when i turned when he
turned 45 46 i was like i started
thinking about i go yo i'm gonna when he
turns 50 his names officially pops you
were planning that for three years oh
wait a little bit more way more than
four years played that long game i
waited so long for that big five zero
you know what the nickname when he
turned 60 is gramps
you're already gramps done
i know it's not easy man but uh
you're doing the right thing and you're
with one of the best so absolutely thank
you guys and thank you all as well um as
always ryan sickler on all social media
ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you